you like the andre agassi look about
that the head here's the thing the
thinner it gets yeah it's good luck if I
don't know if it's when you're thinner
and you can let it go longer yeah it
just looks thinner so like well I have
hair you go like oh it's just parting
and falling like you've got a if you if
you don't go short you're really you're
not doing yourself any all right I mean
can't let the wind pick it up well you
do what Holly doesn't just get the thing
what's that the implants I can't do it
I just can't he's gonna get beard in
blind I'm gonna get beard implants why
don't we do I'm serious why would you
laugh like tell me what you're so I
understand what are you planning on
doing getting beard implants which is
like a hair transplant you hear don't
grow here I looked it up how much as it
is where to go is it a lot sixty five
hundred and would be like everywhere you
know can I just say this yeah just don't
tell people that I'm getting it done I
know I'm seeing it on this podcast I
understand that by the comics don't
listen to this so when I have a full-on
beard I want to show up and have people
go oh yeah he naturally could do that
you hear anywhere else not much what no
like maybe two in his leg yeah they take
the hair from the back of your neck
mm-hmm and they they they put it into
your face and then you shave it
apparently and then just let it grow a
wild I want to look but you got to make
sure it goes everywhere right yeah I'm
not you like I'm in [ __ ] that's my
turn Noble I'm not gonna deter noble
thing gonna that's pretty wild dude I've
never heard of that what it people get
it I looked it up on the internet it's
not yes yeah because we can't do like I
can do this so what I'm gonna try to do
is grow this out these tips mm-hmm down
here so it does a fool Manchu I'm really
perpetuate that look yeah
so when is uh when is that when you set
up how soon you gonna do this well I
figured this because I manifest things
in my life
yep and so this is what I think I think
that I think the show that I'm on is
gonna stay on a while my feeling about
it
it's a code splitting up together it's
gonna stay on and then um I'm gonna reap
you know I think that it's gonna go on
for five six years and I'll just kind of
retire afterwards and I'll disappear for
a while and when I come back I'm gonna
go look like Korean Gimli Lord of the
Rings you know
[Music]